Quand j'étais petite , mon grand-père m'a dit:
"Si tu dis un mot suffisamment souvent, tu deviens ce mot"
Et comme j'ai grandi dans une ville où la ségrégation existait, Baltimore, Maryland,
j'ai en quelque sorte eu cette idée de traverser l'Amérique avec un enregistreur-
vive la technologie-
pour interroger les gens, pensant que, si je marchais dans leurs mots-
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle je ne porte pas de chaussures sur scène-
si je marchais dans leurs mots, je pourrais plûtot absorber l'Amérique.
j'ai aussi été inspirée par Walt Whitman,
qui voulait absorber l'Amérique et se faire aspirer par elle.
Donc ces quatre personnages sont issus de ce travail,
que je fais depuis plusieurs années maintenant,
sur-je ne sais pas-peut-être 2000 personnes
que j'ai interrogées.
Est-ce que quelqu'un ici est assez vieux pour connaître Studs Terkel, ce vieil animateur radio?
Donc , j'ai pensé qu'il serait la personne idéale
à qui demander de parler d'un moment important de l'histoire américaine.
vous savez, il est "né en 1912, l'année du naufrage du Titanic,
le plus grand bateau jamais construit. Il heurte le sommet d'un iceberg,
et bam, il coule. Il a été submergé et j'ai émergé: wow, quel siècle!"
(Rires)
Donc ceci est sa définition d'un moment décisif de l'histoire américaine.
Un moment décisif dans l'histoire américaine, je ne pense pas qu'il y en ait;
vous ne pouvez pas dire Hiroshima, celui-ci est énorme,
je ne peux pas évoquer un moment dont je dirais qu'il est décisif.
Le dérapage progressif -dérapage- c'est bien le terme
utilisé par les gens du Watergate, le dérapage moral-
c'est quelquechose de progressif, c'est une combinaison de choses.
Voyez-vous, nous avons aussi la technologie.
Je vous le dis, de moins en moins d'humanité.
Oh, laissez-moi vous raconter une petite histoire.
L'aéroport d'Atlanta est moderne,
et ils devraient partir de cette porte.
Ces trains, qui vous conduisent à un hall et à une destination.
Et ces trains sont sans heurts,
ils sont tranquilles et efficaces.
Et dans le train il y a une voix, vous savez, c'était une voix humaine.
Voyez-vous, dans le temps nous avions des robots, les robots imitaient les humains.
maintenant, ce sont les humains qui imitent les robots.
Donc on entend cette voix dans le train :Hall1 :Omaha, Lincoln.
Hall 2 :Dallas, Fort Worth. Avec la même voix.
Alors que le train est prêt à partir, il y a ce jeune couple qui court,
et ils sont sur le point de fermer les portes automatiques.
Et cette voix annonce, d'une traite, dit:
"A cause d'une entrée tardive, nous aurons 30 secondes de retard."
Alors là, tout le monde dévisage le couple d'un air hargneux
et le couple va se faire tout petit, vous savez.
Et bien, il se trouve que j'avais pris deux ou trois verres avant de monter à bord-
je fais ça pour m'armer de courage - et donc
j'imite un appel de train, la main posée sur -
"George Orwell, votre heure est venue," vous savez.
Et bien, certains d'entre vous rigolent. Tout le monde rit
quand je dis ça, mais dans le train :silence.
Et tout à coup ils me regardent
Et nous sommes là, ce couple et moi,
attendant tous les trois d'être cloués au pilori, vous voyez.
Et pile à ce moment-là, je vois un bébé, un petit bébé sur les genoux de sa mère.
Je sais qu'il est Hispanique, car sa mère lui parle espagnol.
Et là je me penche pour parler au bébé, et je lui dis,
gardant ma main devant ma bouche car mon haleine doit empester,
Je dis au bébé, "Monsieur ou madame,
quelle est votre opinion sur l'espèce humaine?"
Et le bébé me regarde comme seuls savent le faire les petits
se met à rire,
se met à éclater d'un petit fou rire.
Là, je dis"Dieu merci, on n'a pas perdu toute réaction humaine".
Mais voyez-vous, la touche humaine tend à disparaître.
Vous voyez, vous devez remettre en cause la vérité officielle.
Vous savez ce qui était formidable avec Mark Twain-
vous savez, on respecte Mark Twain, mais on ne le lit pas.
On lit Huck Finn, bien sûr, on lit Huck Finn.
Je veux dire, bien sûr, Huck était formidable.
Rappelez-vous cette scène sur le radeau, vous vous souvenez de ce que Huck a fait?
Vous voyez, Huck , cet enfant illettré, qui n'est jamais allé à l'école,
mais il y a quelque chose en lui.
Et la vérité officielle , la vérité, la loi, c'était
qu'un homme noir était un bien, une chose, vous voyez.
Et Huck monte sur le radeau avec une chose, nommée Jim, vous voyez.
Et il entend Jim dire qu'il va aller récupérerer sa femme et ses enfants
et les voler à la femme qui les possède,
et Huck dit :"Ooh , mon Dieu, ooh, ooh-
cette femme, cette femme n'a jamis fait de mal à personne.
Ooh, il a l'intention de voler , de voler,
il veut faire une chose terrible."
Et juste à ce moment-là, deux esclavagistes, qui cherchent Jim.
"Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un avec vous sur ce radeau?" Huck répond ,"oui".
"Noir ou Blanc? " " Blanc". Et ils s'en vont.
Et Huck dit:"Oh mon Dieu, oh mon Dieu, j'ai menti, j'ai menti, ooh,
J'ai fait une chose terrible, terrible- mais pourquoi est-ce -que je me sens si bien?"
Mais c'est la bonté de Huck, ce dont il est fait,
vous voyez, tout ça, c'était enfoui, tout enfoui.
Donc la touche d'humanité , vous voyez, tend à disparaître.
Donc si vous voulez un moment décisif,
pour moi, il n'y en a pas dans l'histoire américaine.
C'est une accumulation de choses qui fait que nous en sommes là aujourd'hui
où les futilités font l'actualité.
Et de plus en plus, on perd conscience de la douleur.
Huh, vous savez , je ne sais pas si vous allez me suivre ou pas,
mais je citais un écrivain du Nebraska,Wright Morris, qui dit:
on est de plus en plus dans les communications,
et de moins en moins dans la communication.
Okay , les enfants,il faut que je file, que j'aille voir mon cardiologue.
Et voilà, c'était Studs Terkel.
(Applaudissements)
Bon, en parlant de prendre des risques, je vais imiter quelqu'un que personne n'aime.
Vous savez, la plupart des acteurs veulent jouer des gentils-
enfin, pas toujours, mais dans le concept, surtout à une conférence comme celle- ci,
j'aime bien inspirer les gens.
Mais comme on a parlé de prendre des risques,
je vais faire quelqu'un que je ne fais jamais, car elle est si haïssable
qu'un jour , quelqu'un est venu en coulisses,
et m'a dit de la retirer du spectacle.
Et je la joue quand même car je sais que le risque,
à une conférence comme celle-ci,est perçu comme positif.
Mais il y a d'autres connotations au mot"risque",
et de même pour le mot "nature". Qu'est ce que la nature?
Maxine Greene , qui est une formidable philosophe,
qui est aussi âgée que Studs et qui était le chef -
d'une sorte de grande organisation philosophique,
je suis allée la voir et je lui ai demandé quelles étaient les deux choses
qu'elle ne savait pas encore, qu'elle désirait apprendre.
Et elle a répondu "bien, personnellement, j'ai toujours l'impression de devoir faire la révérence
lorsque je croise le président de mon université
Et aussi de devoir aller chercher des cafés
pour mes collègues masculins, même si j'ai survécu à la plupart d'entre eux."
Et elle a dit, "et puis intellectuellement,
je n'en sais pas assez sur l'imagination négative.
Et le 11 septembre nous a bien démontré
que c'est tout un domaine que nous n'étudions pas."
Donc ce qui arrive concerne l'imagination négative.
Cela pose des questions sur ce qu'est la nature, sur ce qu'est Mère Nature,
et sur ce qu'un risque peut être.
Et j'ai pris ceci dans un Institut Correctionnel pour Femmes du Maryland.
Tout ce que je vais dire vient d'une bande enregistrée.
Et je donne des titres aux choses car je pense que les gens parlent en poèmes organiques,
et celui-ci s'appelle "un Miroir à sa bouche."
Et voici une détenue, appelée Paulette Jenkins.
"j'ai appris à cacher ce qui se passait,
parce que je voulais que personne ne sache ce qui se passait chez moi.
Je veux que tout le monde pense qu'on est une famille normale.
je veux dire, on avait tout ce qu'il fallait au plan matériel,
mais cela n'a pas diminué la souffrance de mes enfants;
cela n'a pas diminué leurs angoisses.
A force, je n'avais plus d'excuses pour les yeux au beurre noir,
pour les lèvres éclatées et les bleus. Je n'avais plus d'excuses.
Et il me battait moi aussi. Mais ça n'a rien changé au fait
que c'était un cauchemar pour ma famille ,un cauchemar.
Et là j'ai dramatiquement échoué,
car j'ai laissé faire encore et encore.
Mais la nuit où Myesha a été tuée-
et la tension montait , montait et montait encore
jusqu'à cette nuit où nous sommes rentrés après avoir pris de la drogue,
et il s'est mis en colère contre Myesha et a commencé à la taper,
et il l'a mise dans la baignoire. Oh, il utilisait une ceinture.
Il utilisait une ceinture car il avait cette idée perverse
que Myesha avait des relations sexuelles avec son petit frère
et qu'ils se caressaient-c'était ça son excuse.
Là je parle de la nuit où elle est morte.
Donc il l'a mise dans la baignoire,
et j'étais dans ma chambre avec le bébé.
Et quatre mois avant que ça arrive, quatre mois avant la mort de Myesha,
je croyais pouvoir changer cet homme. Donc j'ai eu un enfant de lui - dingue -
croyant que si je lui donnais son propre enfant, il laisserait les miens tranquilles.
Mais ça n'a pas marché, pas marché.
Et j'ai finalement eu trois enfants, Houston, Myesha et Dominic,
qui avait quatre mois quand je suis arrivée en prison.
Donc j'étais dans la chambre. Comme je disais, il l'avait mise dans la salle de bain,
et ,et à chaque fois qu'il la frappait, elle tombait.
Et elle se cognait la tête contre la baignoire; cela s'est produit plusieurs fois de suite.
J'entendais tout, mais je n'osais pas bouger. Je n'ai pas bougé.
Je ne suis même pas allée voir ce qui se passait.
J'étais juste là, assise, et j'écoutais.
Puis il l'a mise dans le couloir.
Il lui a dit de rester là. Alors elle est restée là pendant 4 ou 5 heures.
Puis, il lui a dit "lève-toi"
Et quand elle s'est levée, elle a dit qu'elle ne voyait plus rien.
Son visage était bleu. Elle avait un oeil au beurre noir.
Sa tête était toute enflée;
elle avait doublé de volume.
Je lui ai dit "laisse -la aller dormir". Il l'a laissée faire.
Le lendemain matin elle était morte.
Il est venu la chercher pour l'emmener à l'école, et il s'est énervé.
Il a dit, "elle ne respire plus"
J'ai su tout de suite qu'elle était morte.
Je ne pouvais pas accepter qu'elle soit morte, donc je suis entrée
et j'ai mis un miroir près de sa bouche,
il n'y avait rien, rien qui sortait de sa bouche.
Il a dit, il a dit, il a dit
qu'on ne pouvait laisser personne savoir ce qui s'était passé.
Il a dit "tu dois m'aider". J'ai dit d'accord, d'accord.
Je veux dire, j'ai gardé le secret pendant des années et des années,
donc j'étais habituée, moi, à continuer de garder un secret.
Donc nous sommes allés au centre commercial, et nous avons dit à la police qu'on l'avait perdue,
qu'elle avait disparu.
Nous avons dit à un vigile qu'elle avait disparu
alors que c'était faux
Et nous avons dit au vigile comment nous l'avions habillée,
et, une fois rentrés, nous l'avons habillée exactement de la même façon
que nous avions décrite au vigile.
Puis nous avons pris le bébé, et mon autre enfant,
et nous avons roulé sur la I-95.
J'étais pétrifiée, engourdie,
tout ce que je pouvais regarder c'était dans le rétroviseur.
Et il l'a allongée là, sur le bas-côté de l'autoroute.
Mon propre enfant, et j'ai laissé faire ça aussi.
Et voilà une enquête sur l'imagination négative.
Applaudissements.
Quand j'ai commencé ce projet
appelé: "Sur la Route : à la recherche de l'Américain-type"
avec mon enregistreur , je croyais aller traverser l'Amérique
et la voir sous tous ses angles: des cavaliers de taureaux, des cow-boys, des éleveurs de porcs,
des majorettes-mais je me suis en quelque sorte embarquée dans les relations raciales
car mon premier vrai spectacle parlait d'une émeute raciale.
Donc je me suis rendue à deux émeutes raciales,
l'une d'elle était celle de Los Angeles. Et j'en ai tiré ce qui va suivre.
Car ce que je voudrais dire,
c'est que c'est de ceci que j'ai appris le plus sur les relations raciales.
C'est une sorte d'aria, je dirais, et sur plusieurs de mes cassettes.
Tout le monde sait que les émeutes de Los Angeles ont eu lieu
car quatre policiers ont battu un Noir, Rodney King.
Cela a été saisi sur film - par la technologie -
et diffusé dans le monde entier.
Tout le monde pensait que les quatre policiers iraient en prison.
Ce ne fut pas le cas, et donc il y a eu des émeutes.
Et ce que beaucoup de gens oublient, c'est qu'il y a eu un second procès
demandé par George Bush Senior
qui s'est fini par la prison pour deux des policiers
et les deux autres déclarés innocents. J'étais à ce procès.
Et les gens dansaient dans les rues
car ils avaient eu peur qu'il y ait d'autres émeutes.
Une explosion de joie, suite à ce verdict.
Mais il y avait une communauté, les Coréens-Américains, qui ne partageait pas cette joie,
car leurs boutiques avaient été incendiées.
Et cette femme, Mme Young-Soon Han,
m'a enseigné le principal de ce que je sais sur les races.
Et elle pose une question en lien avec ce que Studs disait:
la notion de vérité officielle, de demander la vérité officielle.
Donc, ce qu'elle demande ici, elle prend un risque
à demander ce que la justice est dans la société.
Et ceci s'appelle "Ravaler son Amertume."
"J'ai longtemps cru que l'Amérique était la meilleure.
En Corée, j'ai vu beaucoup de beaux films hollywoodiens sur le mode de vie:
je n'ai jamais vu de pauvre, de Noirs.
Jusqu'en 1992 , je croyais que l'Amérique était la meilleure, je le crois toujours,
je ne le nie pas du fait que je sois une victime.
Mais fin 92, lorsque nous étions en pleine tourmente,
et qu'on avait tous ces soucis financiers, mentaux,
j'ai commencé à réaliser que les Coréens
sont complètement laissés pour compte dans cette société et que nous ne sommes rien.
Pourquoi? Pourquoi devons-nous être abandonnés?
Nous n'étions reconnus pour aucun traitement médical, aide alimentaire, GR
aucune assistance sociale, rien. Beaucoup d'Afro-Américains qui ne travaillent pas,
reçoivent un revenu minimum pour survivre.
On n'a rien reçu car nous avons une voiture et une maison.
Et nous payons des impôts élevés Où est la justice?
Ok, Ok, Ok,Ok.
Beaucoup d'Afro-Américains ont cru gagner dans ce procès.
J'étais là, assise, à les regarder le lendemain du verdict,
et toute la journée, ils ont fait la fête, ils ont célébré,
tout South Central, toutes les églises. Et ils disaient,
bon, finalement, la justice a été rendue dans ce pays.
Et bien, où sont les droits des victimes?
Ils ont pris le droit de détruire les boutiques de Coréens innocents.
Ils ont beaucoup de respect, comme moi,pour Martin King.
Il est l'unique modèle pour la communauté noire. Je m'en fous de Jesse Jackson.
Il est le modèle de la non-violence, non-violence,
et ils voudraient être dans son sillage.
Mais 1992 alors? Ils ont détruit des gens innocents.
Et je me demande si ceci est vraiment la justice,
pour eux, de faire valoir leurs droits de cette façon-là.
Je ravalais cette amertume , assise là, à les regarder.
Ils étaient si heureux, mais j'étais contente pour eux.
Contente pour eux. Au moins, ils ont obtenu quelquechose, Ok.
Oublions les victimes, Coréennes et autres,
qui ont été détruites.
Ils se sont battus pour leurs droits pendant deux siècles,
et peut-être parce qu'ils sacrifient d'autres minorités,
Hispaniques, Asiatiques, on souffre davantage .
C'est comme ça que je le comprends,
c'est pourquoi je suis partagée sur ce verdict.
Mais comme je souhaiterais, comme je souhaiterais
pouvoir me réjouir moi aussi.
J'aimerais pouvoir vivre en bonne entente avec la communauté noire.
Mais depuis l'émeute , il y a trop de différence.
Le feu est encore là. Comment vous dire?
Allumer, allumer, allumer le feu. Allumer le feu.
Il est encore là; il peut se rallumer à chaque instant.
Mme Young-Soon Han
Applaudissements.
L'autre raison pour laquelle je ne porte pas de chaussures
c'est au cas où j'aurais envie de me blottir
et de me mettre dans les pieds de quelqu'un
en marchant pour de bon dans ses chaussures.
Et je vous ai dit que en- vous savez, je ne vous ai pas dit l'année,
mais en 79 je croyais que j'allais rencontrer
des cavaliers de taureaux, des éleveurs porcs et des gens comme ça,
et puis j'ai été déviée vers les relations raciales.
Finalement , j'ai bel et bien rencontré un cavalier de taureaux, il y a 2 ans.
Et je suis allée à des rodéos avec lui , et nous nous sommes liés.
Et il lance un article d'opinion que j'ai faite sur la Convention Républicaine.
C'est un Républicain-je ne dirai rien sur mon appartenance à un parti, mais bref-
voici donc mon cher, très cher Brent Williams,
et ceci est sur la résistance,
au cas où quelqu'un aurait besoin de savoir ce qu'être résistant veut dire
dans le travail qu'on fait. Je pense qu'il y a là une vraie leçon.
Et ceci s'appelle "Résistance."
Bon, je suis un optimiste. Je veux dire, à la base , je suis un optimiste.
Je veux dire, vous savez, c'est comme ma femme , Jolene,
sa famille dit tout le temps,
tu sais, tu peux penser que c'est un perdant,
il semble avoir eu tant de malchance, tu sais.
Mais quand ce taureau a piétiné mon foie, tu sais,
je n'ai pas perdu mon foie, j'aurais pu le perdre,
j'ai gardé mon foie, donc je pense que je ne suis pas un perdant.
Je pense que j'ai eu de la chance.
(Rires)
Et , je veux dire, des choses marrantes arrivent parfois.
j'étais chez le médecin pour passer un scanner,
et il y avait un Reader's Digest, d'octobre 2002.
On y parlait de 7 façons d'avoir de la chance. Et ça disait
"si vous voulez avoir de la chance,
vous savez, vous devez avoir des gens positifs autour de vous.
Je veux dire, quand j'ai dit à ma femme que tu voulais venir me voir,
et me parler, et bien elle a dit, elle bavarde tout simplement,
c'est pour être gentille avec toi. Elle ne viendra pas.
Et puis tu m'as appelé et tu m'a dit que tu allais venir
et m'interviewer, et du coup elle a fait des recherches sur toi sur Internet.
Elle m'a dit, regarde qui c'est.
Tu ne seras jamais capable de répondre à ses questions.
(Rires)
Et elle disait que tu allais me faire passer pour un idiot
parce que je n'ai pas fait d'études,
et que je n'aurais pas l'air d'un professionnel et tout ça.
Je lui ai dit, tu vois,cette femme m'a parlé pendant 4 heures.
Vous savez, même si je ne voulais pas parler,
et bien elle voulait que je parle,
je ne pensais même pas qu'elle viendrait jusqu'ici.
La confiance? Et bien je pense que je fais du rodéo
davantage par détermination que par confiance.
Je veux dire, la confiance, c'est comme, vous savez,
vous êtes déjà monté sur ce taureau avant, vous savez que vous en êtes capable.
Je veux dire, la confiance, c'est un peu être trop sûr de soi, mais de façon positive.
Mais la détermination, tu sais, alors, tu sais,"fous la forme,
prends la corne."
(Rires)
C'est Tuff Hedeman, dans le film "8 secondes".
Je veux dire, comme Pat o'Mealey quand j'étais petit,
"tu es le plus tenace de tous les enfants que j'ai vus"
Et le fait de tenter et la détermination, c'est la même chose.
La détermination, c'est que tu vas t'accrocher à ce taureau,
même si tu le chevauches la tête en bas.
La détermination, c'est que tu vas monter
jusqu'à ce que ta tête traine dans la boue.
La liberté? C'est le rodéo.
La beauté? je pense que j'ignore ce qu'est la beauté.
Bon, je pense que c'est probablement le rodéo, aussi.
Je veux dire, regarde comment on est, une famille un peu brute,
des copains qui se serrent la main, et puis qui luttent autour de moi.
Comme quand on se ruine en payant les tickets d'entrées et l'essence.
On fait du rodéo ensemble, tu sais, on mange ensemble
et on dort ensemble.
Je veux dire, je peux même pas imaginer
mon dernier jour de rodéo. Je veux dire, ça va pour moi,
j'ai mon ranch , et tout ce qu'il faut,
mais je veux dire, je ne peux même pas imaginer que ce jour viendra.
Je veux dire, je pense que ce sera
comme le jour où mon frère est mort.
La résistance? et bien, on était à West Jordan, Utah, et ce taureau
m'a fourré la tête dans des morceaux de métal,
tu sais, il m'a bousillé le visage, et j'ai dû aller à l'hôpital.
Et ils ont dû me recoudre et me redresser le nez.
Et je devais retourner au rodéo ce soir-là,
donc je ne voulais pas d'anesthésie,
ou quoi que ce soit de ce type-là. Donc ils m'ont recousu le visage.
Et puis ils devaient me redresser le nez
et ils ont pris des tiges et me les ont rentrées dans le nez
et me les ont remontées jusqu'au cerveau
à tel point que j'avais peur qu'elles ressortent par la tête
et tout le monde disait que ça aurait dû me tuer,
mais ce ne fut pas le cas ,car je pense que j'ai une grande endurance à la douleur.
(Rires)
Mais le point positif, c'est qu'une fois qu'ils ont mis ces tiges là-haut
et redressé mon nez, j'ai pu respirer
ce que je ne pouvais plus faire
depuis que je m'étais cassé le nez au rodéo du lycée.
Merci.
Applaudissements.